DeSANTIS.
SOMEBODY WHO WILL FORCE IT TO
HAPPEN.
>> GENTLEMEN, HOLD THOSE
THOUGHTS FOR A SECOND.
WE'RE GETTING INTO OUR NEWSROOM
A NEWS LIZ CHENEY AD AND SHE
USES A FAMILIAR FACE TO TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THIS TRUMPISM.
>> IN THIS NATION'S 246 YEAR
HISTORY THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A
GREATER THREAT TO OUR REPUBLIC
THAN DONALD TRUMP.
HE TRIED TO STEAL THE LAST
ELECTION USING LIES AND VIOLENCE
TO KEEP HIMSELF IN POWER AFTER
THE VOTERS HAD REJECTED HIM.
HE'S A COWARD.
A REAL MAN WON'T LIE TO HIS
SUPPORTERS.
HE LOST HIS ELECTION AND HE LOST
BIG.
I KNOW IT AND HE KNOWS IT AND
DEEP DOWN I THINK MOST
REPUBLICANS KNOW IT.
>> HOW ABOUT THAT, RON?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, BRING IT --
IT GOES TO THE POINT THAT THE
CONGRESSMAN WAS MAKING ABOUT THE
EVOLUTION OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
IT WAS ONLY 15 YEARS AGO THAT
CHENEY WAS CONSIDERED THE
CONSERVATIVE END OF THE GOP.
DEMOCRATS CALLED HIM VOLDEMORT,
RIGHT.
AND NOW BASKET HE ASCRIBES TO A
VISION OF CONSERVATISM, ON
STRONG GOVERNMENT AND STRONG
NATIONAL DEFENSE AS OPPOSED TO
THIS SENSE OF GRIEVANCE ABOUT
BEING DISPLACED IN A CHANGING
AND DIVERSIFYING COUNTRY, HE'S
KIND OF, YOU KNOW, ON THE OUTS
IN THIS -- IN THIS PARTY.
AND LIZ CHENEY IS I THINK A
PERFECT EMBODIMENT, HIGHLY
UNLIKELY TO WIN HER PRIMARY, BUT
SHE'S SYMBOLIZES A LOT OF THIS
ROUGHLY ONE QUARTER TO ONE
FIFTH, SOMEWHERE IN THERE OF
REPUBLICAN VOTERS WHO ARE DEEPLY
UNEASY WITH THE TRUMP DIRECTION.
BUT YET, HAVE CONTINUED TO VOTE
FOR CANDIDATES ADVANCING IT ON
THE GROUNDS THAT THEY LIKE
DEMOCRATS EVEN LESS.
WHAT DOES SHE DO GOING FORWARD?
WHAT DO THEY DO GOING FORWARD?
WHAT DOES DICK CHENEY AND GEORGE
W. BUSH DO GOING FORWARD AND
THAT IS A CRITICAL QUESTION
ABOUT HOW AMERICAN POLITICS
EVOLVES AND HOW THIS GREAT
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY THIS BECOMES
IN THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS.
>> JOE, YOU CAN'T CALL DICK
CHENEY A RINO.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
RESPONSE TO THAT AD WILL BE?
>> YOU CAN'T, ALISYN.
BUT I'M CALLED A RINO EVERY DAY
AND I'M THE CRAZY TEA PARTY GUY.
EVERY WORD DICK CHENEY SAID IN
THAT AD IS SPOT ON.
BUT HERE IS THE DEAL.
LIZ CHENEY IS GOING TO LOSE IN A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AND SHE'S GOING
TO LOSE SOUNDLY.
BECAUSE THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
BASE DOESN'T GIVE A DAMN ABOUT
ANY OF THAT STUFF ANY MORE.
THEY ARE ENTHRALLED WITH THIS
NOTION OF A STRONG MAN AND A
DICTATOR.
>> OKAY.
JOE WALSH AND RON BROWN.
>> COULD I JUST --
>> VERY QUICKLY.
>> VERY QUICK.
THERE ARE SO MANY CONSERVATIVE
PUNDITS WHO ARE TRYING TO MAKE
THE CASE THAT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY HAS MOVED BEYOND TRUMP.
LOOK AT ARIZONA AND MICHIGAN.
ELECTION DENIES IN ALL OF THE
TOP OFFICES, WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH LIZ CHENEY, THIS IS
A PARTY THAT IS STILL LARGELY IN
ITS THRALL AND EVEN MORE, IT IS
ANIMATED BY THE SAME THAT HE